for
e
e for
yours are several of that fine yours
aren't
there um so let's again Define it I
think you were here maybe okay you have
the IM spiral and you have the outward
spiral and really if you were to Define
them struct
on the inward spiral the relationship
between the elbow and the wrist is what
you is what defines it so on the inward
spiral the wrist goes in and the elbow
goes out on the outward spiral is the
reverse the elbow goes in and the wrist
goes out okay it doesn't have to be that
this all the time okay doesn't have to
be that all the time so you want want
that the coiling energy which is
generated from the wrist and the elbow
rotating around themselves okay so I
don't want to have straight
arms like this you see so the wrist and
the elbow don't really
change relationship you see that they
stay in the alignment and they
go they stay in the
alignment okay uh here's the
outward the elbow came in again I'll do
it
again and the inward the elbow goes out
the wrist comes in and it can be very
small just like you did it so it kind of
looks like the other
one but it's not
okay you have
to okay you have to do the shapes so
when whatever whatever it is so even if
you you see this like sometimes you'll
see me do that a lot but the elbow's
going to come in you see it came in just
ever so
slightly ever so slightly
so it's coil it's coiling around itself
uh careful with
this here here here no they coil around
they coil around coil around coil around
coil around coil around so here not here
they didn't coil coil here you see
not
here right
here or
here okay
um so let's try to tr get the arm
patterns going okay and understand it
more accurately